[Music]
well my name is john walker and i'm the
chairman of the ramsgate society which
is the civic society for the town of
ramsgate we've been established for
about 57 years i think it is and we've
got about 700 members
[Music]
well from our point of view the ramsgate
society we're very keen on the maritime
history of the town
and we've been looking out to the museum
and keeping it open to the public
and we've had this vision about five or
six years ago to completely transform
the building to
regenerate it and to have a new modern
heritage center here and to turn
the peer yard which is in front of this
building that we're in now into a lovely
town square where people can gather so
we think
that's a priority
for the plan and we understand tdc have
included it in this current round of the
leveling up bid which we just heard has
been successful
it's their plan basically it's their
town and it's their plan and although
it's been led by thank district council
it's very much a joint venture with the
council and they're very keen to know
what people think and for people to
engage
with the delivery of the plan so i
encourage people to get involved
[Music]
you